could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i wanted to be powerful and have
influence because i wanted to prove
people wrong you can't start the
internet for very long without stumbling
upon lily's sink lily
i was born into the reality of being a
disappointment right away there were
rules about being a woman my mom did not
grow up with queer culture so for me to
expect her to operate from a place of my
lived experience how is that math ever
going to add up
welcome to the first episode of a little
late with lilly singh you got given a
late night show when i said that you
said i'm so sorry tell me why you said
that because i don't think the thing was
good
the community that i did this show for
is pissed at me because i nervously made
a joke out of context and that broke my
heart every day did you have anxiety at
the time i developed it during season
one of the show
is the struggle worth it for me yes it
is i believe in what i believe so much
more than the hurt that i feel
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
lily
thank you for being here it's a real
honor and we've got a mutual friend jay
shelley who's really spoken so
incredibly highly of you and then when i
got a chance to delve into your story i
became pretty fascinated by many things
i want to start because i always i
always believe that the foundation of
everybody that i sit here with and also
myself having studied some childhood
psychology is their childhood so i guess
the question i had for you is
when you think about 10 year old lily
and the lessons she had learned by that
age about the world and life
what were those lessons and where did
she learn them from
the lessons at the age of 10 i don't
think were necessarily beneficial ones
um
i was
born into the reality of
being a disappointment right away being
the second daughter in an indian family
i was told in my adult life that my
grandparents great grandparents and
india didn't find out about my birth for
about two weeks because they had said if
it's not a sun is not worth calling home
about so that really colored in a lot of
my childhood because whether it was
ridiculous things like
oh you know girls aren't supposed to
talk that much ridiculous things like
girls aren't supposed to whistle
whatever girls weren't supposed to do
was very apparent to me from a really
young age so the lessons i was taught
that there were rules about being a
woman there was expectations about being
a woman
and i had to
fit that mold if i wanted to be
not even accepted but if i want to make
people proud i think more than anything
i never felt like i wasn't accepted but
if i wanted to be
extraordinary in the eyes of people that
were disappointed in me i had to fit the
mold and so a lot of my upbringing was a
little bit of this
uh simultaneous i need to fit the mold
but then this rebellious side of me
being like but i don't want to and kind
of negotiating that balance
what you said about your grandparents
wanting a boy and generally in an indian
culture they're being a desire to have a
boy how did that impact you
i i read that you were a tomboy growing
up yes yes yes yes i was obsessed with
doing the rock johnson i loved wrestling
i wore baggy clothes i rebelled in every
such a way because of this expectation
that was set upon me i think in my adult
life i have learned and i don't think i
knew this growing up i don't think i
even knew this years ago i think this is
a quite recent revelation
that experience has put a very heavy
chip on my shoulder that i carry in my
adult life and i think for a lot of my
life i was
scared to admit that or i was
embarrassed to admit that because no one
wants to admit that they have this chip
on their shoulder but now i fully
embrace it that ship on the shoulder is
for most of my life i always felt like i
had to prove myself in every instance no
matter what it was whether it was school
grades whether it was my dancing ability
whether it was
how i could speak up at a family party
no but in every instant i always felt
like i had to prove myself worthy
because i was born into this reality
where
being a girl is lesser in indian culture
and that has followed me into my adult
life and if you look at the pattern of
everything i've done in my career i've
only now connected the dots that the
common thread between all of that is
proving myself
and so even when i started making
youtube videos in 2010 a lot of people
asked me why did you do that and i can
give you the answer that i think people
want to hear which was i wanted to
create a path and no one else was doing
what i was doing and sure that's all
true to some extent but the real reason
was i wanted to be
powerful and to have influence because i
wanted to prove people wrong i think
that has always been that chip on my
shoulder i wanted to prove that being a
girl
was worthy of celebration and so that
has been a thing that has followed me so
so that is truly the chip on my shoulder
that now i'm just fully transparent
about
when i think about my own insecurities
and the things i pursued at like 18
years old they were all the opposite of
the thing that invalidated me when i was
a kid so when i was a kid only black kid
in an all-white school parents with a
broke family and a perfect white picket
right you know neighborhood and so my
pursuit in life was like if i had the
things that i'd missed as a child if i
had money and if i was i'd know famous
or whatever then it would be filling
some kind of childhood void i wonder
when you said then i wanted to be
powerful and have influence is that
because you
you didn't when you were younger as well
is that part of it i think it's more so
that the people who are the most
powerful in my upbringing were men
they were
the men in my family the men at a family
party that were in the corn they got to
control a conversation what they said
goes
men notoriously in indian culture are
the decision makers the powerful people
and i know one thing that the men in and
i don't want to paint all indian culture
or men but i'm just saying as a kid it
was evident to me that the uncles made
the decisions they got to decide what
was acceptable not acceptable and so i
knew one thing that the men would
understand was power money and influence
and so i think i strived for a career
that would give me those things so i
could kind of prove a point to them
being like you may not understand my
value in any other way aside from money
power and influence and to some extent i
was not wrong i've done a lot of cool
things in my life but the things that
really
made my dad and my uncles go wide-eyed
were things like the forbes list where
things like oh she's in a headline she
has her own show those are the things
that they understand to be of value and
i'm not saying that's right or wrong and
i'm not trying to dissect if it's right
or wrong i just knew they would
understand that and so for me to have an
impact
of course i want to help people of
course i want to pave the path that's
all true
but those are not the things that the
people that had power as a kid for me
would understand they understand power
money and influence so i would be lying
to say that that wasn't a driving factor
and you so you moved to la your youtube
career starts really gaining traction
you said it a second ago that you
pursued youtube because of your very
honest power and influence right but
when you start on youtube there's no
guarantee of power and influence right i
know your first video did like 70 views
or something crazy yeah yeah
so when you started youtube a very
strange thing to be doing back then
recording yourself especially doing like
funny stuff in your room or whatever for
sure what what were you thinking like
what was that yeah i was thinking a few
things one was that i was always a very
creative kid i was the kid that wanted
to be the center of the dance circle at
a family party i wanted i watched ace of
cakes i wanted to bake cakes i wanted to
be creative through any means necessary
but i think i was convinced that
creativity was a phase that it's
something you do as a pastime as a kid
your career shouldn't be creative you
let go of that you get a real job et
cetera et cetera when i was in
university and i discovered youtube it
was a glimpse of
i could be creative as an as an adult i
could
express myself in a way that's like on
my own terms there is no gatekeeper
there's no rules this was
something that i got to make the rules
about i got to decide i built a little
community of people that also were in a
little bit of a dark place so i got this
sense of connection that i wasn't
getting in real life um and the real
real talk of it is that i'm an obsessive
person
once i started making youtube videos i
was obsessed with it i was obsessed with
learning how to do it well
exploring how else i could be creative
learning how to get more views learning
how to market myself i with everything i
do i'm a very all or nothing person
which has been
a great pro but also very detrimental in
my life um this type of obsessive
personality especially if you you become
obsessed about something that isn't
fully aligned right which is possible
right because there can be two
conflicting forces the force can be i
want to be really successful and then
the other force can be saying well this
isn't my purpose and
they can surely come into it's also very
problematic when you're obsessive over
something that is governed by numbers
that is a very dangerous combination
when you're obsessive and your success
is measured by views and subscribers and
stats that is a bad recipe right there
because i would actually
be this is 2010 before youtube had a had
very complex analytics now you can see
and now you can you can know how many
people with dogs on their laps are
watching your videos like it's intense
how many analytics you can get now back
in the day that wasn't the case i would
actually have my own spreadsheets like a
crazy person just on my wall
every day tracking okay how many views
this video did this many subscribers
there's people like an obsessive degree
and i don't regret that because it
got me great success but i've had to
slowly unlearn a little bit of that to
not go completely crazy in my adult life
before that youtube phase with the
spreadsheets and stuff like that
did people consider you to be a lazy
person did they do they like count you
out
one thing i can say is i've been called
a lot of things in my life
i have never been called lazy so when
you were because that that phase before
the youtube and the spreadsheets right
what were you doing with your in your
life at that phase so i was applying to
grad school i had just finished
graduating and i was applying to grad
school and let me let me put an asterisk
to my last comment i'm sure my parents
would call me lazy from time to time
it wasn't lazy as much it was as it was
my heart is not in this thing so i do
not
i do not think it is worthy for me to
put my energy into it that's what i was
getting at yes which is how someone can
go from being perceived by their parents
or in my case by school as being i got
kicked out of school for the same thing
and then just years later they can see
that i'm obsessed when something is in
line with something has caught me like a
fish on a home right exactly better or
for worse maybe it's caught one of my
insecurities and dragged me off into the
future whatever
but i just thought that was interesting
that like maybe in that phase of your
life others would look at you and go oh
she's lost because
the moment i walked into my parents room
and i said i want to make youtube videos
um what i actually was doing five
minutes before that is i was right
trying to write an essay to get into
grad school and it was bad and i was
like i'm not this makes no sense i don't
even care about the outcome of this i
closed my laptop right then and there
and i said if i don't care about this
i'm not gonna do well in this and so i
really had to shift my focus somewhere
else and that literally five minutes
later i went to my parents room and i
said i can't do this
i want to try making videos on the
internet and they were like
say what now um this was in 2010 and
they gave me the best advice ever and
the best blessing ever which was you
have a year so they also give me a bit
of a ticking time bomb they said you
have a year to try whatever you want to
try whatever this youtube thing is you
have a year and if it doesn't work out
you will go to grad school and you will
do exactly what you were doing five
minutes ago and so i also had a bit of a
a time period that i had to figure
things out in which was a huge blessing
because it made me every moment for that
year work on making this pop off
when you had that conversation with your
parents how big were you on youtube if
at all
not that big not that big at all i think
i had like my views were in the
thousands probably okay um and this was
2010 like i said so i vividly remember
when i hit 1 000 subscribers now your
cat can meow and you will have like
10 000 subscribers but this was a
a lot of hustle to get to even a
thousand i know this because i made a a
justin bieber never seen every parody
when thousands of breakfast i was like
i've made it baby
when you reflect now on the role that
your parents were playing in your life
like even then like having to go to them
and then like granting you this year
it all sounds incredibly like imprisoned
you know what i mean
yes i think for a lot for a lot of my
teenage years my young adult years i
probably viewed it like that i no longer
do i've done a lot of work to try to
figure out and respect my parents
context which has really really helped
me in their circumstances and really put
value to it not just dismiss it so i
actually think a lot of what they did
although the moment didn't seem right
and even now a little questionable
sometimes it actually really helped me
like this one year if they were so
liberal to me and let me do whatever i
might have not worked as hard in that
one year to be honest
you know and if they did not teach me
the value of a lot of the things that
they value i probably wouldn't be the
person i am today so i actually don't
hold that against them at all it's
really interesting mo god a guy that
came on this podcast said that when he
used to work at google when they
interviewed people and said would you
erase the most traumatic or difficult
moments of your life um
knowing that it would erase all the
lessons it taught you as well and
everything that came with it would
people do it 99 of people said they
wouldn't no and there's an interesting
thing about how we look back on our
trauma because we also don't know the
other outcome because it's interesting
it's
and i agree when people ask me in
interviews what would you say to your
younger self and what would you change i
always say i wouldn't change anything
because even those like horrible
decisions those questionable moments
they have all resulted in something
really really great that's the exchange
of the universe and that's just how
things work magically um
and it's interesting how knowing that
right now i can sit here and tell you
that i would not change anything about
my past any trauma any pain even knowing
that
i will still sit here today and think
that the pain i'm experiencing today is
intolerable
and not acknowledge that 10 years from
now i will probably say the same thing
about the pain i'm experiencing today
something to always keep in mind
we have this way of humans as humans of
thinking that whatever pain we're
experiencing right now is for sure
definitely the worst pain and it cannot
get worse it always does
and we always think that it's still the
worst pain when you were a kid you
thought i remember when i was a kid my
mom i said i couldn't get this shirt it
said backstreet girls on it and i
remember thinking this is the worst day
of my life and my life is never gonna
get worse than this i remember thinking
that i'm gonna run away my mom hates me
she won't let me be a backstreet girl
how dare her and then years years later
something else happened i thought that
was the worst and we keep doing that as
humans don't we we keep thinking that
whatever this is today this is the worst
that perspective completely true
completely true been through it myself a
million times i always say you know this
is
the current crisis always feels like the
fatal one until hindsight tells you that
the current one is the failure right um
but what does even knowing that it still
doesn't seem in my case to stop the
current crisis feeling
faithful it helps a little bit takes the
edge off but when we're in the heart of
the storm for whatever reason
what else helps you to gain perspective
on the situation i mean like really i
don't mean like the advice that we give
in our books and stuff i mean right what
actually helps
what actually helps me when i'm going
through pain and i can't see myself
coming out the other side
is
truly to i'm a very
logical person in the sense that i
always think about things through
to the best of my ability
facts or like diagrams i just have this
brain that likes processing things and
so i think about
okay
what is my success rate of getting
through things
it's actually 100 right now i sit here
at 100 we all sit here everyone watching
actually you sit at 100 right now no
matter what yeah 100 is where you said
that so i think about things through
that lens but i also think about
just is the struggle worth it
and
for me yes it is i believe in what i
believe so much more than i the hurt
that i feel and that's the balance i
think we need to keep in check is it
worth it is your struggle worth it and i
think you really need to do the work to
make that answer yes
and i didn't always
operate from a yes
but i think now i do i believe
i found my purpose and i know jay talks
about this a lot but finding your
purpose and what your purpose is on this
planet helps you get to that yes so for
me
i think my
my struggles are worth it i think the
pain is worth it to get on the end
you became
a hugely i'm going to look back to that
sort of topic in a section but to give
the listeners a context you became a
hugely hugely successful
social media star creator whatever you
want to call it
um
built one of the biggest youtube
channels still to to this day some
millions of millions of subscribers yeah
that is uh that makes you in the 0.0
whatever percent anomalies in the world
so i hear the obsessive thing you said
about the spreadsheets i guess that i
thought for her to get there she must be
pretty obsessed i walked in here and you
were like ooh she has google doc written
all over her well like there's like but
we all i think at times in our lives
probably look back and think i was also
probably toxic obsessive you know
because the things that i was ex you
know especially when you're in the
numbers business right and the metrics
business so what else about you when you
think about that phase of your life from
2000 and
you know maybe 13 when you hit a million
subs to where you hit
14 point whatever seven million subs
what was it about lily outside of the
obsessive part
that made you
such an anomaly through that phase of
like
career success in youtube
this has required a lot of reflection
because um
i was trying to think recently
what my purpose is going back to our
previous conversation what is my purpose
because i i thought my purpose was
specific projects i would work on
specific things in the industry and i
kept thinking that's too small that's
that's such a in the moment purpose like
what is your greater purpose so i had to
go look back through my life recently
like what is the common thread here and
the common thread between everything
especially during this time period
you're talking about can be summarized
in one word and that is disrupter
i think my purpose is to disrupt and i
think i've done it continuously in my
life from being a tomboy as a kid to
being outspoken in a room full of uncles
to getting into the entertainment
industry not through an agent not
through moving to la but through youtube
where there are no gatekeepers from
the first late night host wherever that
historic moment was like i continuously
feel the need to disrupt not because i
am actively trying to disrupt because it
is just who i am as a person and i know
this even on the personal side
um
the first
openly queer person to host a late night
show the first woman of color first i've
just been associated with so many firsts
and i used to hate it like i used to i
remember thinking and telling my
therapist
i don't want to be the first i don't
want to be the first anymore i hate
being the first i don't want the
pressure of all this i just want to do
what i love doing
and my therapist joked and said yeah you
need to pick a cause you got a lot of
things going you have to pick an issue
but i have since embraced that instead
of looking at it as a
thing that i hate about myself and i
want to change about myself and that
causes me stress i haven't accepted that
it is my purpose to disrupt it is just
how i am built i am built to break
systems and molds again not because i'm
actively trying to stir the pot but
because it is just how my brain and my
being operates i have to break molds
so when you ask me that question between
that time period what was it about lily
it's that lily always would ask the
question of how else can this be done
and why isn't this being done this way
and maybe there's a different way of
doing it and when she gets told that
this is the way things usually are done
i just simply do not accept that i
everyone on my team knows that's the
worst thing you can say to like this is
how things are traditionally done i just
don't accept that with anything
clearly you're someone who's built a lot
of evidence that the look you just gave
me is the look my parents give me just
like no yeah do you know there was so
much going on in my head and then i was
thinking about different ways to take
that and different feelings i got from
that yeah one of them honestly was like
especially hearing the obsessive thing
listen when i ask these questions i'm
not because i think because i relate to
so much of what you're saying yeah i'm
asking the questions to to pick dig
deeper not because i no i love it i love
it but it's just
the look is like my parents looking at
me like yeah right she likes to distract
her yeah because my brain went my brain
went oh my
she's so even when you were delivering
it so passionate that i felt i was like
that's exhausting to be obsessed it's
exhausting on the other hand i was
thinking
why is your brain wired to disrupt
things like why so i understand the from
an innovation perspective it's going to
be fruitful you're going to create new
things but why is that your
predisposition is it going back to your
childhood and saying i think still like
the system i have asked that question to
myself as well why is that no matter and
this is where it can be to a detriment
sometimes because sometimes i'll take
simple simple tasks that are don't need
that much effort but i will make it so
i'm disrupting even those small small
things maybe there's a different way to
throw a party maybe there's a different
way to have a friendship maybe there's a
different way to decorate my house and
every aspect i have to disrupt and it is
exhausting it's absolutely exhausting
and i've tried to figure out why why
what is it in me
i'm still trying to figure it out but i
think
from my work thus far i've determined
that it's just that from the moment i
was born i was already a disruption i
was already that and i think that's just
me stepping into my power fully
embracing that's who i am and being like
fine i'm not gonna
reject that i am going to fully embrace
that's my purpose in life because
another thing is
you know when you ask me about the chip
on my shoulder
the part of the story i didn't say is
that i actually did come out the other
end so in my adult life when i announced
my first world tour after becoming a
youtube success i very purposely
announced it in india i was like i want
to announce the tour in india i want the
first stops to be in india i know that's
where you know my great-grandparents are
now that's where my parents are from i
know it'll mean the most there to have
the biggest impact so after i announced
that tour i went and did the eight-hour
drive to visit my grandfather for the
first time in my adult life i had never
met him as an adult before and
this was the the grandfather where and i
hold nothing against him because i again
i respect people's circumstances but he
was the one that didn't want to hear
about a daughter who didn't believe a a
daughter in the family would be
worthwhile
he was standing outside of his house and
greeted me with a flower garland and he
said the words to me this is like an 80
year old indian man said the words to me
i was wrong you have made this family
more proud than anyone else could have
ever done and he showed me all these
newspaper clippings he had saved with me
so that moment for me
also validated
what disruption can do
it can make progress
progress comes from disruption and
breaking systems and so i think that for
me was a very and i i remember it so
vividly because it did leave such an
impact on me but that for me was like
look this is what disruption can do this
is what the uncomfortable
process results in
and am i right in therefore concluding
that that disrupt the the fuel of the
disruption was that chip on your
shoulder
and it creates almost a bit of an
injustice and a sense of anger in people
that i've seen so many times in myself
and thinking about my friend umar who's
come comes from a somewhat similar
background an indian guy went on to
create a billion dollar company he he he
grew up with this internal just almost
frustration anger this sense of trying
to correct an injustice and that
manifests this chip on its shoulder and
i guess life
if you start with that predisposition
and you go through life with that idea
of like disrupting the status quo
you will win and that will reinforce
that yes so now imagine when i work with
you if i came up with a conventional
idea you know from 33 years of
experience that the rewards are on the
other side of the disruptive you know
what we call first principle thinking
when you go to the extra effort of
thinking about something from fresh
right and that's um it's that
i also will be really honest i thought
that that moment of
uh my grandfather knows now he knows
what's up he knows my name would
eliminate the chip on my shoulder it
didn't
i don't think it will ever actually go
away why um i'm still trying to figure
that out i think it's because that same
chip is still reinforced in so many
other places in the world
it's still that i'm was the only female
late night host and so when i was at
that seat in that table surrounded by
men that chip was just reinforced it's
like a neutron exactly so i think it
keeps getting reinforced it was never
just about my grandfather it was just
about the system but that is also i
would just say i have to get really
honest and say that mixed with ego once
you get a bit of success i think jay-z
says success is the most addictive drug
it is once you disrupt and it comes out
the other end and you see how amazing it
is you're like i just keep doing this i
keep doing this i need to keep
disrupting i need to that's been
something i've had to
really
meditate on in my adult life is that
when does that stop when does that
desire just more and more and more and
more disrupt disrupt when when when when
does that stop yeah that can be the real
enemy of happiness right absolutely
yes happiness is often right here but we
can't see it because we're still trying
to chase it that way we're still trying
to it's always the
it's in the future mentality you know
happiness will come success will come
these things will come maybe it's like
right now
right even saying that there is not
enough right now yeah because i say that
to a lot of people but still struggle
with it you have to do a lot of work
it's a lot of work it's not just where
it's a lot of work and how you assign
value to yourself how you assign value
to other things for most of my life i've
hustled so i built an entire brand out
of hustling anyone that knows anything
about me it's a hustle harder hustle she
wrote how to be a boss or first book
it's a
now
over the past two years i've done the
work to not hustle less i still work
very very hard but it's what does all
this stuff actually mean what is the
value you tied to this stuff is what you
thought it was going to be i think you
can only learn that once you get there
and you get it and you're like oh it's
not giving me the feeling i thought it
was going to give me and it probably
never will because of this value we've
assigned to all this stuff
have you gotten to the point where you
you know that you are enough
who this is turning to therapy what did
you think it was gonna be clearly never
listen to this vodka okay i'm gonna
cancel my therapy appointment
i saved myself 300 um
we charge
um
i am just now actively right now in the
process of believing that
through writing my latest book my latest
book was a lot about that it was about
am i enough right now because i think
i'll be honest it's a buzz word oh you
are enough like for example kids are
born these days and we it's the first
words we tell them are you enough you're
not you're great just the way you are
i think we need to find the balance of
hard work and spirituality of business
and spirituality there's intersection of
these things where yes i think now i'm a
full complete human being does that mean
i don't have goals and aspirations i
don't want things i still have all of
those things but i'm at the point right
now where
those things whether i have them or
don't have them will not impact the way
i define myself
see a lot of
my life i've defined myself as youtube
sensation
late night host actress who has this
role
i am doing the work to realize that i'm
actually a complete human being that has
value aside from that and those things
are just cool things and experiences i
get to do and i can strive to be great
at them i can perfect my craft but i'm
not
lesser if i don't have those things and
i'm not more if i do have those things
this is an active thing i'm working on
and when you get to that place if we are
lucky enough in our lives to get to the
place where we realize we're enough
that's you know i had this really
interesting conflict in my life which
i'm sure that listeners have heard about
before where
when someone said to me one day maybe
seven years ago they said you need to
realize that you're already enough i
remember thinking what a load of
[ __ ] yep i'm not gonna get out of
bed if i have that viewpoint i don't
need to strive for anything [ __ ] get
out my office right and then upon
reflecting on that writing my book
whatever
i realized that my thought that knowing
you're enough inhibits ambition is
actually false what it does knowing your
enough kills fake ambition the minute i
knew i started to get closer to
realizing that i was enough my ambitions
were all things that i actually wanted
that were actually in line with my so
it's this weird paradox of when you know
you're enough it doesn't inhibit
ambition it's the foundation of real
ambition it gives you a lot of clarity i
think and you're absolutely correct
because
when you don't feel like you're enough
everything feels important
everything feels like something you have
to obtain everything feels like a
challenge you know when i didn't feel
like i was enough and i felt like i am
the late night host i am this actor i i
am my job this is what defines me if
anyone asks me who i was i would never
answer as
i'm patient friend i'm a nice i would be
like i'm
in this show i mean that's how i would
or i would define myself by my struggles
which is another whole thing not by ever
my potential i would never say i'm
someone who's gonna change the world
because of xyz i would say i'm someone
who had a really tough childhood we
either define ourselves by our struggles
or by these other external validations
and accolades that we think are
important
when i did that i would care so much for
me what was so important was i need to
prove this troll wrong on the internet i
need to that's that's my priority i need
to prove this troll wrong i need to get
this rating i need to and then the
second i was like you know what
my purpose is to disrupt uh i know what
my values i'm a complete person already
suddenly that stuff became way less
important to me
suddenly i was like oh actually my
priority is going to be
i want to tell stories that i think are
really
meaningful i'm not saying that it has to
be a box office breaker
in that i'm saying i just wanna tell
stories that are important you things
become a little more clear when you
accept you make space for priorities to
become clear when you stop pretending
that all this other stuff is important
so i totally agree that is something i
struggled with where i thought and i
think that was my resistance against it
when people would tell me you're enough
and when they just tell kids they're
like no that kid's gonna grow up and
they're not gonna they're not gonna
become anything if you just tell them
they're enough
again i still think that there's
a intersection between hustling and
spirituality i don't think we have to
pick one or the other i really don't i
think there's a way for both of those
things to co-exist but i do it has
become apparent to me that
being mindful
feeling like you're enough
it actually allows you to hustle with
more clarity
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together we call
it fitness blockchain and i'm currently
at 81 percent um so 81 of the days i've
done a workout in the last 150 days
right so i'm going to the gym about six
times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivative live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one you know when people are saying
oh you need to get this rating and
you're thinking well i'm going to prove
them wrong and whatever and you're
getting dragged by external you know
measurements or validation and then you
get to the point where you say you know
what i actually just want to tell
stories
people reach that crossroads a lot in
their life where they've kind of like
built an identity in your case tens of
millions of followers by doing something
and then you know in other people's
cases it could be they're working in as
a lawyer and then they they catch sight
of what their purpose might be and at
that crossroads life says to you if you
go down that route you're going to lose
a lot of this stuff that you've built i
know it's not aligned with you but
you're going to lose friends a network
an identity don't go down that road
right and you face that so clearly in
your life that crossroads
and even leaving youtube
you know when you have
14 million
you have your damn mind yeah but yeah
totally but tell me so like at that
crossroads in life what advice would you
give to people when in your case you're
one of the ones that really had
you know i don't want to say a lot to
lose because that's a presumption right
so it's like
the public would think that you had a
lot to lose by taking a different route
right
you're absolutely correct i think one of
the reasons i for so long kept holding
on to the strings of youtube to be like
no i want to do other stuff but i'm
still going to do this i want to do that
stuff but i'm still going to make these
videos i'm still going to dress up as my
parents was that it was that i didn't
want to lose this traction i had this
audience i had this instant
gratification i had of having this
massive audience at my fingertips i also
to be honest i was scared of this
term relevancy i think relevancy is used
as currency these days like you're not
relevant so you're worth less now and we
have this
this way to measure people based on
relevancy this
can be summarized in one easy sentence
which is you cannot expect to grow and
also stay the same
it just cannot happen you have to make
room for growth and so
in order for me to fulfill my ambitions
of i want to do stuff with movies and
tvs and i want to i want to just do all
this other stuff that is me growing in
my craft i cannot stay the same i can
you have to make space for that you know
i also always think about if i have
again going me going back to diagrams
and the way my brain thinks if i have
100 energy at the start of a day i can
only spend 100 energy no more energy is
coming i you have a hundred so where are
you going to put that energy it can be
to old habits it can be to holding on to
the relevancy but then that limits how
much energy is left for growth so it
really is just a decision you have to
make of making room for growth
and when you did
make that decision back in 2019 to to
was it 2019 you left youtube
i still ok
yeah but yeah i think around 2009 to
where i stopped consistently uploading
videos yes so um
when i read about why you left youtube
there was clearly some symptoms of life
saying to you
you're [ __ ] up here in some way what
were those symptoms
i think doing things because you feel
like you have to doing things because
you feel like you owe people doing
things that you're not really passionate
about um and feeling like you don't you
haven't given yourself permission to
grow and how does it emotionally feel
um
stagnant i felt like
i was trapped i felt like i owed people
this version of myself that was stuck in
space and that was not allowed to grow i
felt not creative i felt um
not free
and i felt like
even though i what i loved about youtube
was freedom i can post whatever i want
whenever i want there's no gatekeepers
i felt trapped in that system it became
the exact opposite of what i loved about
youtube which was you have to serve
every monday and thursday you have to
post a video you have to appease these
fans it has to be like this has to be
this long if it is the algorithm it
became the exact same thing i never
wanted in the first place which was to
be trapped in something like that and so
um it just it stopped feeling right to
me it stopped feeling like a place that
i could grow and learn and thrive the
lily that i would see on camera at that
point in the lead up to you deciding to
depart versus the lily that would be
there right after you stopped recording
tell me the difference between those two
people yeah she's just as weird in both
instances i can tell you that she's just
as weird she's just as quirky but one of
them was definitely a bit more
performative
pretending to be a little bit more
passionate than she was
pretending not to be tired and exhausted
and pretending to be excited about what
she was doing i think after i turned off
the camera i was like oh god i gotta
edit this thing i gotta do this thing i
gotta go through these there was no
growth it was just such a repetitive
pattern and
as a creative i didn't want that that's
if i wanted that i would have just done
the grad school thing right
and then obviously you get this big um
opportunity which is well written about
and i've watched the episodes i've
watched season one and season two first
grapes no no
why did you say i'm so sorry
so first of all the context of the for
people that don't know so you got given
a late night show you were the first
woman of color
to be like over 30 years yet and over 30
is to be led into that
boys club
on a major network
when i said that you said i'm so sorry
tell me why you said that because i
don't think the thing was good
and i'm not
necessarily proud of it you know
when i
got the show
again me being the streptor the whole
first season the the advertising was
we're gonna break the mold we're
knocking down the doors of late night
we're gonna do things differently and
then i proceeded to do things pretty
much exactly how they've always been
done why um because
for the first time in my life i was in a
situation where i could not call the
shots
i couldn't make the decisions i didn't
have the resources to do things
differently the system is not built to
do the issue the system is not built to
do things differently
it's hard to do things differently when
you're told okay so the episode has to
be exactly 22 minutes and 23 seconds it
has to be that amount of time can't be a
second over it cannot be under the acts
have to be broken down like this because
our commercials have to go in these time
things so you had a joke that went there
can't go there anymore you have to do it
like this oh you're following jimmy and
seth and the audience is kind of used to
their formats you can do things
differently but it has to start with a
monologue so you have to come out you
have to hit the mark you have to do the
monologue
so many times when i did that monologue
which was the worst part of the show it
was like a 10 minute monologue of
mediocre jokes because i had a
tiny writer's room and very few
resources this is to no discredit to the
writers i just had such few writers that
were too overworked
there were
episodes where i would miss the mark and
i would mess up and it was the best part
of the show and i would have to do it
again
to get it right and i would always think
why can't we just put the mess up on air
the best part of the show even beyond
that was before we were even rolling i
would go out and i would warm up the
audience and i would just riff with them
and talk some jokes and it would be so
just natural and funny and you would
never see that in the show
why
we didn't have enough cameras to shoot
the audience so
we couldn't put it in the show so the
system was not built for
breaking the mold
at that time did your gut tell you
something was wrong absolutely from day
one i thought
this is going to be very hard
it's gonna be very hard to make
something that i'm proud of here and i
when what i hated about it was the
proudness and the pride was of something
superficial i was proud of the headline
i was proud of the historic nature of it
i was proud that i got to make history
but none of
the work could back it up and that broke
my heart every day to know that i'm just
riding this headline and i'm not going
to be able to deliver on this there was
episodes i visually remember this there
was a several episodes where i would be
with my
we didn't even have a showrunner it was
my head of development for my production
company who acted as the showrunner for
the show and i would be walking and the
show would be starting in five minutes
and we would be going over the monologue
and i looked at her one and i said
this is not funny
and this is not good and i don't want to
go out there and i don't want to have to
pretend it is
and she looked at me and she said
it's a quantity game it's not a quality
game and that broke my heart because
late night is a quantity game it's i
shot 96 episodes in three months and i
don't want to come across if i'm
complaining and all this but
i'm trying to highlight that
it was very difficult for me to go into
the system being the control freak guy
and being the disrupter and just try
everything to disrupt it and it's just
too rock solid to be disrupted
i asked these questions in part because
i've just joined a show called dragon's
den okay which is like shark tank yeah
yeah five of us that investor walks in
and since then i've been offered a lot
more shows right
and
i mean you've been there right loads of
[ __ ] loads of proofs coming in for shows
big promises whatever
and some of them are really tempting
because it says oh you're gonna be on
netflix but then my gut says to me
that's a [ __ ] show though that is a
piece of [ __ ] so i'm asking from a
perspective of advice when you find
yourself in the
in the shadow in the shadow of a great
temptation i'm you know steve butler
might be the first whatever whatever
whatever but i but i look at what's
going on the system in which i would be
operating as you did
what advice would you give to me based
on the lesson you've learned in
hindsight
i will answer this question by telling
you exactly that the lesson i learned
which is
it wasn't until the show finished that i
really had to reflect on that experience
be like what am i gonna do differently
you see when i was offered the show the
first time it was brought to me i
actually said no people don't know this
i said no
and it disappeared for like a month and
it came back to me again and i thought
okay the universe is sending this back
to me again let me let me evaluate this
the reason i said no first was because i
never grew up with the dream of being a
late night host i know some people have
that experience where they're like i
grew up with late night television
watched every night
i don't think my mom could tell you what
jimmy's last name is like she they never
watched late night they i never grew up
with that experience so it wasn't my
desire it wasn't my passion to be a host
um so that's why i said no but when it
came back around and it was explained to
me the historic nature of this
three things came into play one my sense
of responsibility and duty and to my ego
those things together i was like i want
to be part of this historic moment that
would be really cool also i have a
responsibility for this because what if
i say no and it goes to someone else
then this history is never even made and
we never even got this shot so all of
these
reasons that i thought were so valuable
and valid is why i said yes i was naive
to think that that would be enough to
get me through those long shoot days it
wasn't because i would come home at the
end of
96 episodes in three months
broken and i would think
that
was not fun and i didn't enjoy that and
i have no memory or no positive thought
to even show for that hard work
i learned the value of having fun
and doing things you're passionate about
i believe more than anything else those
are the things that actually contribute
to longevity more than anything else
even money ask any person with a lot of
money
you'll go tired of money you'll go tired
of buying things you will never grow
tired of having fun and being passionate
about something and so since i wrapped
that show any project that comes to my
desk now
my agents will be on the phone and we'll
talk about the money for a while we'll
talk about the schedule for a while and
then i'll dedicate an amount of time
i'll say okay now we're going to talk
about if i'm going to have fun and if
these people are actually nice to work
with and do i even care about this do i
care about this and what is this do i
even care about the message here what
this is saying if my answers are no
my definition of success right now is
that i will not say yes to it i have to
have fun right now where i am or i'm not
successful so that's my advice to you is
don't undervalue fun and passion because
those
you will never go tired of those things
it makes it even more difficult in that
situation where you're coming home after
filming those nuts by the way which is a
ridiculous number of anything
this should do the math for everyone
that's two to three episodes a day
and traditionally late night house do
one a day
so you're coming home exhausted after
doing something that you didn't find fun
right and then
the exacerbating factor of all of that
which i i reflect on and i say to myself
steve you've been able to deal with this
part as well is the show was by some
people well-received but by others
heavily criticized
specifically the community which is the
youtube community you'd come from
people made very hurtful very
shallow
criticisms sometimes your personal
criticisms about you in the show yeah
unless you're
the superwoman
which is the pseudonym i think he used
to go under that has got to
doing something you don't enjoy that is
not aligned with you and then being
criticized for it
is like the holy trinity of a bad place
to be right 100 even you saying this has
given me a fourth pimple on my cheek and
i'm sweating because it does it does
evoke an emotional response out of me
and it's not just the youtube community
it was the south asian community that i
got critics from it was a queer
community that chris says
every and every community there was
people not all but there were some
people that were criticizing me that's a
really hard pill to swallow when i just
finished telling you that part of the
reason i said yes to the show was to
help pave a path i felt a responsibility
to communities
the tough part about being a minority
anything
is that so many people are counting on
you to reflect their experience the best
you can do is reflect your own the best
i could have ever done is talk about my
experience
and my lived circumstances
that's never going to satisfy over a
billion south asian people
queer people women that's half of the
population right there there's no way
and that's the hard pill to swallow to
know that you can go out there try your
best and still because you're the only
one
people are going to criticize you i
think that is not discussed enough about
why it's so hard to break through it's
because
so many people are counting on you it's
an unrealistic expectation i also had to
and this is way easier said than done
and i'm still working on it i had to
learn
not and i mean this with love but i mean
this very bluntly not to take advice
from people giving it from inside their
comfort zone
the amount of people
especially on youtube that would
criticize
the jokes on my show the delivery on my
show the
sound quality of my show without ever
never having stepped foot into a late
night studio
as a logical person i have to i have to
shut that down
because that's the equivalent of me
watching basketball and being like you
missed that three-point shot oh my god i
could never make that shot so i really
had to retrain my brain
to
take away value from certain people and
add value if jimmy fallon wanted to give
me critique on my show i would have been
all ears and taken notes and been like
thank you so much but if some person on
the internet has never done this i
simply cannot take their critique
seriously and i know some people hear
that and they think that's a really
perhaps
snobby way of looking at things but not
really no practically speaking you
cannot take advice from people
who are doing it from inside their
comfort zone because they actually don't
know what they're talking about
in that period and especially in this
sort of the cloud of that criticism
was there a particular day where you go
that was my hardest day emotionally how
i felt where it all just got because
i've had those moments in my life where
all the factors just line up on one
particular day and i think yeah yeah
this one's hard to talk about but for
the sake of having honest conversation
in my first season
the first season was by far way tougher
than the second the second i
tried to make it more fun i put more of
my team into the staff i trust but the
first season was really tough this was
the 96 episodes in three months i talked
of
this was um we didn't even have a show
runner
we had half a dozen writers which is
half of what usually late night shows
have
i was just worked
to such an extreme like my from morning
to night was just at that studio i was a
writer i was trying to produce i was
trying to host i was just in such a bad
state
and
one of the tasks that was on my plate
because of me i said i had to do this
was i had to watch every single episode
before it would air so at the end of a
shoot day at like 10 p.m
i would sit alone in that studio and i'd
watch the episode to be like
is this good and then
one of the eps said you don't need to do
this we can watch the show for you take
this off your plate and after much
convincing i was like you know what
today
i'm so tired i'm not gonna watch this
episode
this episode was my interview with
jessica alba
and even though it was not the first
episode to air it was the first one we
shot because we shot out of watch was
the very first episode we shot i'm
obviously so nervous i'm so new to this
i'm trying to be funny
jessica alba had made a comment about
her kids and how they tied towels on
their head with cherby twists and
in an effort to try to be funny and try
to sound personable and make her kids
not embarrassed i said oh i have lots of
friends that tie turbans and in my head
when i said it i was like it's the
coolest thing ever there's nothing to be
embarrassed about like i'm so familiar
of course not hearing the sentence of
towels on heads and turbans in the same
sentence and how that could be really
problematic historically
that was the one and only episode i did
not watch before it aired the one out of
96 episodes and the very next day i was
getting dragged on twitter
the sick community was so upset at me
i apologized profusely
and
i remember that day i was just the
lowest i've ever been where i thought
the community that i did this show for
is pissed at me because i nervously made
a joke out of context
i didn't watch that one episode so i
beat myself up about that and then i
watched every single episode after that
again and tortured myself all over again
but that was really tough for me to to
to feel like i let so many people down
to feel that i didn't get the benefit of
the doubt of just being a human being
that was nervous and misspoke and to
also
have this idea validated in my brain
that oh if you don't do 300 if you don't
watch every episode if you don't do
every job it's gonna come back to bite
you so that was a very unhealthy moment
for me um and that was a really tough
day if i was a flow on the wall that day
in your room in your bedroom what would
i have seen
a lot of crying i think i cried though
like
in my green room that day
i remember my friend actually came to
visit me because he was like oh i know
you're in bad state i didn't even
realize he was there i was just staring
into space the whole day just
i just felt like crap
the whole day
for weeks i still do talking about it i
still feel like crap
did you have anxiety at the time i
developed it during season one of the
show she developed here i never was an
anxious person
um
i think
2019 this show maybe even leading up to
the show i definitely developed anxiety
for sure where i would like be in my
green room not
being able to control
my body's responses not being able to
control my thoughts like that definitely
was something that developed during that
first season of late night
and then the second season you enjoyed
it much more i enjoyed it much more
because
i was able to make some changes i
thought we're not gonna shoot a studio
i'm gonna shoot in a house i'm not gonna
do a monologue i'm gonna do a rant these
things alleviated some of the pressure
from me um did i still think it was the
most amazing thing we ever made no i
thought it was better but the thing is
people had already made up their mind
after the first season
after that first season because it
wasn't instantly which is another tough
thing about any new voice trying to do
every anything
if you don't impress people right away
they're giving up on you
like the second season of the show
i truly believe if that was the first
season of the show
people would have been like oh she
actually broke the mall she's doing
something different but you can't get
there you gotta go through the process
trial and error you gotta every show in
history has taken many seasons to find
his voice and find its footing
but it's the when you are a minority
you're just not given the benefit of the
doubt you know
there's something that i really take
away from this as well which kind of
goes back to the first question i asked
on the topic which is um that even in
the face of like temptation i need to
make sure that i hold on to my values my
professional you know my personal values
and you know people offering me a
netflix show whatever if it compromises
my like creative and personal values
then i have to say no regardless of
temptation until they are going to allow
me to do it in line with who who i am
like the creativity that you have that
made you successful
may i offer you a please a devil's
advocate perspective here because i've
also had this conversation my brain lots
and lots of times
i wish
that
i'm just i'm going to speak from the
south asian experience specifically as
well because that's my lived experience
but i wish
we could hold out for when we're allowed
to do things exactly how we want to for
them to get done
i truly believe if we were to all do
that nothing would get made
and i think that everything is progress
and so i think it's balancing the line
of like i want to be true to my passion
my vision but there is a little bit of
compromise i have found has to happen
and as painful as it is that's why i
don't regret the late night show i think
that compromise had to happen
because when you when i'm in rooms right
now with my production company and i'm
having meetings with netflix and the
hulu's and all these people
the room of people giving me notes
do not look like me they still do not
so the option i have is to
mold the show into a way that is
slightly palatable for them so it gets
made
so that another show like this could
potentially get made and i use never
have i ever as an example the historic
show on netflix is number one in 30
countries because of that show other
shows like that will get green light
other south asian stories will get
greenlit because of that show so that
show has proved to be
a great
path paper for sure
do i believe in my heart that that's the
exact show the creators wanted to make
and that they didn't have to no i think
they had to understand that progress
has to be made so often when i'm in
these rooms
i get irked and i think
you're not understanding the cultural
nuance i don't want to cave on this i
don't want to explain to you what diwali
is i don't want to have to phrase this
like this i have to ask myself the
question
is it better to hold my ground and have
the show not be made or is it better
to get it made
seventy percent of the way i wanted to
be made so that the next iteration of
the show can be 80 and then 90 and then
100 that is the reality of minority
storytelling right now and i wish it
wasn't but that's what it is so it's
negotiating those that reality a little
bit as well and that's not just a
just a minority storytelling thing
that's like i was thinking about various
facets of life and business and
negotiation when there are multiple
factors at play there are stakeholders
who have a say they're investors there's
a timeline that constrains you there's a
limitation on resources right as you
described all of these factors cause an
unavoidable compromise where you have to
go
you know but i guess it's that balancing
act of like what are my non-negotiables
then what am i completely not willing to
negotiate on um
after the second season of the call you
get a call saying that the show's not
going to be continued
tell me about that day
so
i'm gonna describe it as mutual although
yes the network does control like what's
what they're gonna put money towards or
not
i was secretly hoping two things and
they're both completely contradictory
half of me was like
i know this show is a win for the
community it has to keep going it has to
keep going or else it's going to be a
fail for the community so i wanted it to
keep going the second part of me was
i really hope this show doesn't keep
going because i'm going to literally
collapse and die if this keeps going
um
and i always
judge things by what my gut reaction is
to them so when i got that call
my gut reaction was actual relief that's
how i knew that it was the universe
doing me a favor i would never do for
myself because if they let me i would
have tortured myself for 10 more seasons
honestly i would have the universe gave
me something to never got myself
i got that call
i felt a wave of relief
knowing i would never have to torture
myself in that exact situation again but
it also going back to what our purposes
and getting clarity it made things a lot
more clear in my mind and in that moment
i was able to see oh this has been a
huge distraction from what i actually
care about and i actually want to do
this was an obligation this was
something i thought i had to do this is
not my passion it was never your passion
never once did i say i wanted to be a
late night host i did say i want to act
i did say i want to tell stories i want
to produce all of those ambitions paused
during the late night show i couldn't
audition i couldn't do anything else i
literally sacrificed two years of my
life for something that i didn't even
want to do that's a sad sad thing that's
a sad realization so i think i was
rewarded with a lot of clarity in that
moment but what did your ego say in that
moment well obviously my ego was bruised
of course my ego was bruised i didn't do
i didn't do good enough if i had done
better um
i've let people down
i
should have gotten more seasons this is
a bad look how do i make myself seem
like a winner all of that stuff
yeah very honest yes
same thing yeah i have things in my life
at the moment where i'm in the exact
same position where i'm like i don't
know if i
love doing this but if i was fired from
doing it or if they said they don't want
to continue
i would be in the same conflict like i
think there's certain things in my life
that aren't aligned with me completely
but at the same time you kind of want to
make sure it's done on your own terms
and that's the ego right no one wants to
be rejected no one wants to be canceled
no one wants to feel like they could not
do something especially publicly
right it's not a private rejection it's
a public it's a very public type of
rejection so definitely my ego was
bruised um
and i think
more than anything
i learned from that experience that part
of the problem
is that i
easily put labels on myself and i think
we do this to ourselves and do with
other people as well i just kept calling
myself first late night host first this
first late night host has to do this and
i have to do this and that pressure like
i'm not just that i'm someone who
tried really hard at this new thing and
had to learn a new like all that contact
is it's worthwhile context so now when i
think about myself through that context
i have more compassion for myself
and it pains me that other people also
didn't give me that context but i can't
control other people i can control
myself i do that to myself as harsh as
other people were to me i was way more
harsh
i had to put way more pressure on myself
and
since that experience i have also
learned to not label myself so i just
got this new show this muppet show that
i was like wanted so badly and i was
like oh my god i have to get this i have
to get this is gonna be a life-changing
thing and the day i got it
i had to have a talk with myself to be
like you are not now
the lead of the muppet show that's not
now your label you will not now describe
yourself as this thing because then
that's just gonna be the late night host
again it's going to be the youtube
sensation again you are lilly you are a
complete human being this is a cool
thing you get to do that's one of your
goals great you get to do it you take
experience but this is not now your
definition i think part of that struggle
with late night was it just became every
part of who i was and so people weren't
criticizing the show they're criticizing
me they're criticizing every part of me
and who i was and that's just a really
unhealthy boundary amen you know and
people do that i've noticed i've done
that more in my life when
i didn't think i was enough so my
identity or the label would make me make
sense to the world it would make me
you know put me in a community i would
become
social media ceo and then the problem is
social media or any of these labels you
described comes with a set of implicit
instructions on how to behave and how to
be and how to act and that can be really
imprisoning generally i wrote this
chapter in my book called resisting your
labels because of how imprisoning
they've been in my whole life and also
you know as we're going to get on to
with you now when i left my label so
when i was no longer a social media ceo
i had a bit of an existential crisis and
life goes well just go be another one
again because that's what you are and i
think that's when people have these like
midlife crises where they realize they
spent the last 10 years or whatever
being the label and not the person
you leave
the late night show
how was life like for the next year
well in the pandemic role exactly that
was right around the time of the
pandemic so i think that was
a very strange time because i couldn't
bounce back into anything else really
everything was shut down
and my plate was pretty empty because my
gigs were cancelled my travels were
canceled projects were canned everything
was
paused so it was a very hard time to let
go of something that was keeping you
busy and that was how you defined
yourself
through the pandemic and i think a lot
of people can agree with this the
biggest silver lining was the work i was
forced to do on myself
and is when i wrote this second book be
a triangle because the thing about the
pandemic was it wasn't just that i
didn't know what to do with my time
it was that was the first time i was
faced with the reality
of
me not believing i had any value because
i didn't have work
and that was a sad scary realization for
me it was the first time my schedule
allowed me to sit there and be like now
i'm alone and i'm with my thoughts and i
feel like i'm ceasing to exist as a
person because i don't have a purpose
and i don't have value and that's really
sad because that means every time work
goes away i will feel this way and
that's not
that's not what i want
that's not setting me up for success
that's not setting me up for a
spiritually happy life and so i did the
work to really dive deep into my soul
and be like
you're gonna figure this out and what i
came to the conclusion of is that
i
don't have any original thoughts when it
comes to who i am as a person and what i
want out of life and what i value out of
life everything i've operated on has
been what people have told me whether
it's school whether it's my parents
whether society
i have never given thought into what it
is i actually want i never thought that
was an option it sounds ridiculous to
say but i guarantee you people that are
listening to this will actu actually
also think and be like wait have have i
ever done that ever stop to be like let
me work on myself like a project and let
me actually think about life as it's the
greatest project i'm ever going to work
on and so
i vowed during the pound pandemic to
create a
strong foundation for my life what does
that mean because that's a fluff word
and you know i hate fluff words i've
already expressed i hate fluff words and
so how i define a foundation is i wanted
to create a
safe place in my mind that i could
return home to
that was not connected to anything
external and not connected to what was
happening in my life because my biggest
fear was that
the pandemic would be over and then i
would have work stuff happening again
and then again i would just teeter to
happy sad success fail whatever was
happening in my life i would change to
my core and i didn't like that i wanted
to create something that was true to me
and no matter if i won 15 oscars from
tomorrow or i failed tomorrow that safe
place in my mind would still exist and
so that's what i did in this book i came
up with four things that i don't think
will ever change in my life to make up
the foundation
of that safe place in my mind
and that's why
you call it well good good good good
question he's like so the illuminati
be a triangle yeah yeah so when i
discovered that a foundation is what i
needed to create i jumped onto google
and i was just like how to build a
strong foundation foundation and google
spit back
the triangle because structurally
speaking the triangle is the strongest
shape it has the strongest foundation
out of any shape and then i started to
think about triangles a lot and i was
like oh my my brain is very visual like
i expressed and i think of things in
diagrams and i started to visualize a
triangle and i thought the shape is
actually really interesting because
when you add to any other shape you
change the shape it turns into something
else you add to a square becomes a
rectangle you add to a circle it becomes
an oval you add to a triangle
it stays a triangle it just becomes a
bigger triangle and i thought that's
really interesting i want to build my
life like that where no matter what
happens what experiences come my way i'm
still building on this foundation that
will not change
because especially in this industry
and all industries you could really
easily lose yourself but what's
happening in your life but the goal is
to create something that doesn't allow
that to happen and the triangle is the
perfect shape for that and what is the
what constitutes your foundation what
are the ingredients of your foundation
if it was a recipe yeah so i talk about
four things that make up the the
foundation of my triangle i know the
hardest part of this book was figuring
out what those four things are
um and how i did it was i looked for
several months i looked at every
struggle and issue or conflict in my
life and i looked at it through the lens
of four things
that was one way i determined them the
second way was what are four things that
will never ever change no matter what's
happening in my life so i came up with
four pillars which are relationship to
yourself relationship to the universe
understanding distraction
and implementing design i think no
matter where you are in your life who
you are what job you have what country
you live in how old you are those four
things are always true in your life and
it is the lens to which you can look at
everything in your life through
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as you might
know crafted one of the sponsors of this
podcast and crafted are a jewelry brand
and they make really meaningful pieces
of jewellery and this piece by crafted
when i put it on for me it represents
courage it represents ambition it
represents being calm and loving and
respectful and nurturing while also
being the antithesis of that seemingly
the antithesis of that which is um
sometimes a little bit aggressive with
my goals and determined and courageous
and brave the really wonderful thing
about crafted jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made on that point of
distraction which i'm going to talk
about because it was it was a big part
of your book and you you referenced
there that you'd nev the pandemic was
the only time in your life where you'd
really been forced to
all the distraction fell away and you
were left with yourself um so many
people that i know and i'm sure you'll
you can relate to this um
fill their lives with distraction and
noise and things and busyness to avoid
stillness to avoid meditation or taking
time to their for their own mind
you you've picked up meditation and
breath work and things like that can you
speak to me a little bit about the the
impact that's had on on you specifically
breath work because i'm getting a little
bit more into this at the moment yeah
when i read that you'd start doing it i
thought
and i'm still let me preface by saying
i'm so novice and there's much to learn
i'm just starting my journey with really
getting into meditation and breath work
but
i um over the past year
started to have
so this is from like a scientific point
of view before i even hit the spiritual
point of view i started to have panic
attacks which i thought i knew what they
were i think most people who have not
had a panic attack they think it's the
same as an anxiety attack they think
it's like oh you're really stressed and
you don't know how to deal with what's
happening in your life that's what i
thought a panic attack was until i had a
panic attack and i'm like i was very
different
the first time it happened i just missed
it because i was like i don't know what
that was the second time it happened i
was like this is a reoccurring thing i
was talking to my friend
and we were talking about something so
unrelated it was like he was telling me
a funny story about work and suddenly in
my brain
i started to get outside my body like i
was watching myself and i started to
have these really strange thoughts like
i think i'm gonna
take my head and slam it against the
table for no apparent reason and i'm not
gonna be able to stop myself and then i
started spiraling i'm like and then i'm
gonna have to call the ambulance and i'm
gonna be bleeding and everyone's gonna
be and then it's just like you
progressively are just spiraling to
being sure that you're gonna smack your
head against the table and nothing you
say can change your mind this is a
minute of just completely irrational
dangerous thought and then
suddenly i was like oh wait no
no i can i can stop myself from hitting
my head on the table
of course i can stop myself that is a
panic attack it's happened once before
to me when i was driving and i was like
i'm going to drive off this cliff and
there's nothing i can do that's going to
stop me i won't be able to control
myself it's going to happen
when that sort of happened i talked to
my therapist about it
and she explained to me that as someone
who always operates on 10
because i'm always just working really
hard and i'm always thinking about the
next thing i'm an all-or-nothing dead
person i have an obsessive personality
that some things can trigger my nervous
system just go a little bit into
overdrive and that's the body's response
it's it's going into overdrive your
nervous system doesn't know what to do
breath work really helps with that it's
just bringing your nervous system back
down to a state that's not not an 11
you're bringing it back down so from a
scientific point of view breath work has
been my saving grace to just health
having said that from spirituality
it's just my belief of you know i talk
about these pillars and i talk about a
connection with yourself
meditation is
you making time for the partnership with
yourself you know i believe we're all in
a relationship to ourself whether we
want to acknowledge it or not most of us
are bad partners to ourselves we don't
make time for ourselves we don't listen
to ourselves
um
if anyone treated us how we treat
ourselves we would not be in a
relationship with that person probably
so meditation is more than anything else
it's not about religion it's not about
doing something so specifically it's
about making time to be in a
relationship with yourself and that's
something i really really value and i
think that's a huge form of self-love so
from a spiritual point of view also
meditation is my everything some people
are really avoidant of like that time
with themselves though i think it is
because sometimes when i talk about
meditation the a common response i get
is
oh i'm not good at that that doesn't
work for me and i ask why and they say
well i i can't turn my brain off i have
all these thoughts that go in my brain
and then so i'm not doing it right and
my response to them is who says that's
not right
maybe what you need is to hear those
thoughts maybe you've not given your
brain a chance to get those thoughts out
and what you need during meditation is
to hear those thoughts who says that's
wrong
the only thing meditation the only i'd
say if there's one rule of meditation is
just spending time with yourself
whether that's you hearing these
thoughts that are uncomfortable it's not
about problem solving it's not about
solving everything it's just about
giving time to yourself allowing
yourself the space and energy to be like
i care about myself i dedicated these 15
20 minutes to hearing myself out that is
the only
only thing
in the book as well i think chapter six
you start you talked a little bit about
your difficulties with making friends as
an adult yes
uh yes so
um one of the things that i have come to
terms with is that i like i've been
mentioning i'm a very all or nothing
type person across the board and it has
been good in some instances because it
has allowed me success in my career but
is bad in some instances because
when human things don't live up to my
expectation i write them off in
situations where i don't have to
um i'm throwing a party
uh this party has to be the best
everyone that rsvp has to show up and if
they and so i'll throw this amazing
party that everyone has fun at but if
one person didn't show up that said they
were gonna show up
in my brain i go
well it was nothing it wasn't good it
wasn't exactly what i thought if it's
all or nothing there's no middle i have
learned that that is not healthy and
that it and that that also hinders me
because there will be no joy and
there'll be no celebration there'll be
no progress if you're all or nothing i
did that with friendships
i told this to jay jay is my friend in
l.a but for a long time i struggled
because my definition of friendship was
all which meant you have to know me
since i was a kid you have to know me
before i was famous you have to know me
before all of these things so that's a
true friend and so my definition of
friendship was very rigid
and so when i met jay later on in my
life i struggled with that because i was
like he's such a good friend he's so
supportive but ah he didn't know me like
how my other friends know me from back
in toronto so i i don't really know if
this is a real french no you gotta let
go of these definitions and these labels
we put on things and
and be a little more organic with things
because that's where humans lie in that
compromised organic space
when i heard the thing the analogy you
gave about the party one person not
showing up and you being like well yeah
it's not perfect yeah um that sounded
probably
like also the underlying reason why you
were so successful yeah that's what i'm
saying so that's why it's been so hard
to challenge that belief because it has
served me so well so i think now what
i'm learning is when that serves me and
when it doesn't that's actually been a
lot of my work in this book it's not
being mad at myself or having certain
thought patterns and not trying to
completely do a 180 and be like now i'm
not that person anymore it is learning
which ideas
serve me well in certain circumstances
and which ones do not it's unlearning
this idea that i have to be one thing
all the time for example
speaking of labels i call myself a
hustler i hustle really hard as i hold
my whole brand and i found that on days
when i was lazy and i felt like just so
tired there would be a lot of resistance
in my brain because i wasn't living up
to my own label
i was
doing the opposite of this label i put
on myself but i've learned you cannot be
everything all the time we exist on
various places on various spectrums and
so it's not about changing who you are
as a person it's about learning
what ideas serve you well in certain
circumstances and which ones do not and
then
on and off on and off on
have you got a lot of friends
people might think i have a lot of
friends i wouldn't say i have a lot of
friends i think i have a good number of
friends
and it depends how i define friend
people that i can call just to call and
ask how they are without an agenda for
the phone call
like five
four five
i think that's a good number i'm not mad
at that number
yeah i mean it's a good number i think
especially as we get older i mean jay
we're talking about jay shetty by the
way um me and jay were talking about
this the other day about how when when
you get older in life as well the the
amount of friends you have it becomes
increasingly harder you don't have the
work thing you don't have the university
school whatever so really it's more
about depth and quantity as opposed to
your producer it's also a little bit
about um
at least in my experience
watching the adults in my life as a kid
they never prioritize friendship and
they never place value in friendship and
so i believe for a long time that as you
grow up
you need to value
the companion you have as a partner and
that takes the place of friendship and
you don't have time for friendship
because you have a job i have since
unsubscribed to that idea
um
i never saw anyone value friendship that
doesn't mean i can't value friendship as
an adult and i've actually learned this
from jj is very good at maintaining
friendships jay's the type of person
that will message you with no agenda
you're like hey just checking in just
saying hi so i've started to reciprocate
that to him and call him and facetime
him just be what's up
but that's something i had to actively
learn because growing up i don't think i
could name one adult that was like i'm
going to go out with my friends
were you comfortable with friendship in
both platonic and romantic
were you comfortable with it because i
remember think because i grew up in a
similar way i genuinely would cringe and
feel deeply uncomfortable when someone
said the word best friend oh i don't use
the term best for anyone today even
today i tell you this steve is my best
friend and my body oh my god i'm so glad
you said this because everyone knows i
do not use unless you're talking about
my dog who can do no wrong i do not use
the term best friend because i do have
this little bit of like
cringe-ness where i'm like that means i
rely on you and work with the head and i
don't know if i want that so there is a
little bit of work to be done there
still um
but yeah that's interesting i thought
that was only me no yeah i think i said
this to a couple of guests and you're
the first one to 100 100 people that are
like oh they're my best friend i'm like
oh it sounds dangerous but that
i i've learned that with that comes a
commitment issue romantically so i i
also would run from any prospect of sort
of romantic commitment because that also
it felt like a
bird trapped in a cage it felt like
prison to me so in the same way that
friendship was just like yeah
i think it's because my parents weren't
affectionate they weren't affectionate
at all to be honest we didn't have that
very close relationship that a lot of my
white friends did i don't even call my
mum and dad mum and dad i call them by
their names i mean you probably can't do
it no i could never did i get slapped up
in the face if i did that it was just a
distance also what it is is
you know i talk a lot in the book about
unsubscribing to ideas that do not serve
us but i encourage people to look at
everything in their life as an idea
a lot of things we think are fact and
our rules are just ideas they're still
just ideas so what we even think of
friendship's supposed to look like what
we think a relationship is supposed to
look like how we think a romantic
relationship is supposed to be those are
all just ideas and i think because i
thought they were facts like it has to
look one way i resisted that a lot just
like i did with friendship i just told
you with a romantic relationship i do
the same thing that means that you have
to sacrifice a lot there's a lot of
compromise you can design any
relationship the way you want as long as
two people are on the same page so i
encourage everyone to think about that i
think what has really helped me get over
some of the anxiety with commitment
relationships is it doesn't have to be
this idea of what i think it doesn't
need to be this one way i can design one
that works for me and someone else as
long as we're on the same page
i'm trying to figure out where to go
with this because i want to go down the
relationship route but i'm also gonna
there's a there's a point you're talking
about unsubscribing from ideas one of
the ideas you talk about unsubscribing
from in the book in chapter three is
about the the idea of success and what
that is and the definition of it if lily
at 60 years old told me she was
successful
what would that mean
see if you asked me this years ago i
would have answered this question
in relation to accolades i would have
said numbers i would have said oh that
means she's made had made several movies
that are box office hits
now my answer and i it's been a hard
journey to get here but genuinely my
answer is that at 60 year old 60 years
old i still fully understand and believe
i'm a complete human being and
everything that has happened is just
extra cool stuff my goal is to never
write another book
truly
i know i said that after my first book
and i'm saying it again right now my
goal is that this book can be can be the
blueprint for that safe place in my life
forever that i never have to
make another blueprint that is true if i
never write another book again that
means that i was successful in this week
so truly 60 years from now i want to
know that i'm fully complete and
anything that would have happened or
didn't happen was just life experiences
goals cool stuff but it's not i'm not
lesser or more because of it
relationships then romantic ones yes
have you been uh
difficult to date
difficult to find romantic love
probably
absolutely i'm sure all of my exes right
now were like do you have to think about
it
absolutely if i asked your exes
why it was you were you know in their
point of view why you were difficult
what would be the common response the
most common response
that
a few things
one would be that i have an inability to
forgive
ooh i do
um
that i am very transparent about this
might scare people off but as soon as i
know i'm going to get into a
relationship with someone i very
honestly tell them i say
one of my weaknesses is that if you lie
to me or wrong me and betray my trust it
is very difficult for me to trust you
again even if every part of me wants to
i will not be able to and i tell people
this very very honestly where does that
come from i'll tell you right now um i
didn't know first i thought it was like
oh from my childhood from this was but
no i think that's all a lie
i think my inability to forgive people
stems from my inability to forgive
myself
i think that because i expect perfection
for myself and i for so long didn't give
myself grace to be human i didn't give
people grace to be human either and as
i've done the work to treat myself like
more of a human and to be and to to have
the inner dialogue of like it's okay
it's okay you don't always have to be
performing you don't always have to be
perfect you're allowed to be a human
you're allowed to be lazy or allowed to
be flawed the more i've done that work i
have given people permission to do that
as well in my relationships i've noticed
since writing this book one of the
biggest changes i've seen in my
relationships is that
i can actually forgive people now
and i think it's because i've learned to
forgive myself
i've learned to embrace humans for being
humans and that started with myself so
that is something that nx would
definitely say
also with the fact that i have very high
expectations all of my exes will say i
have absurdly high expectations
ouch yeah
that's a tough one the expectation one
are you in love now
i'm in love with
myself
which is the most important love i think
and i think that's perhaps why i was
never a good partner before i don't
think i was ever
unconditionally in love with myself my
love for myself is always very
conditional
always based on my performance always
based on my ability to
accomplish never just for like the
things that were me
yeah you know you had such a high
standard for yourself you talked about
that obsessiveness and even that the
party if one person's not there it's not
perfect
are you saying that that same level of
expectation would sometimes be mirrored
onto the person you would expect them to
be 100 wildly ambitious or because i had
this perspective i'm like why aren't you
changing the world why aren't you some
of my past relationships definitely it
would irk me if i was working
and the person i was with was not and i
don't even mean had a job i mean if i'm
working at two in the morning you should
be working at two in the morning we
should both be equally as ambitious that
i i notice that sounds ridiculous and
i'm admitting that i was wrong and
that's not a good perspective to have
but that's how i felt like i want
someone equally as ambitious since then
what i have learned
is that what i thought i wanted if i was
actually dating someone that was just
like me that would be horrific me and
jay talk about this all the time
me and jay talk about how
both of us in some part of our life
thought that we wanted to be with
someone just like us me and jay are so
similar
we in any time anyone is having a
disagreement we take the same side we
always have the same perspective we're
so similar
and since meeting jay i've learned that
oh if me and jay were in a relationship
we would kill each other we would
actually hate each other because there's
no balance there
you need someone to balance you out and
bring something else to the table amen
and i have fully acknowledged that now
and i think i was a little delusional in
some of my past relationships thinking i
wanted me
but i don't who that no none of it you
might think you want that but you would
kill that person you're totally right
you know my girlfriend now is very much
in every way the opposite of me and that
is in fact as you've described that is
actually the value of our relationship
is one plus one e will equal three when
we have different perspectives and
healthy debates around things like that
right um
i've never asked anybody this question
before but oh my god i love it hit me
what is the the one question because i
when i saw that you've done it you know
you're on a book tour at the moment
you've got a great book that's that's
just come out april 14th yeah and on
that i was watching you do all of these
interviews and doing some great shows
and things and i was thinking to myself
having been in this process over the
last week where everyone's asking you
questions
what is the most
uncomfortable question
you think that i could ask you
that would make me feel uncomfortable
yeah
it can be a topic
or a question you kind of already asked
it to be honest
for me it's it i get very uncomfortable
when we talk about people critiquing
things i worked very hard on because
those are my babies my projects are my
babies and
it
to be just really blunt it hurts my
feelings and i think i thought for a
long time i had to put on a facade that
it doesn't hurt my feelings but it does
i think i am a sensitive artist in a lot
of ways and so
the question you asked about people
criticizing the show i think that is the
most uncomfortable question you could
probably ask aside from that
another really uncomfortable question
i have been asked this though is
in the book i talk about
my experience coming out to my parents
and that is really uncomfortable because
i'll just be really honest a lot of
times when anyone tells a story about
their coming out experience people's
instant reaction is you're right
everyone should have been very
understanding you should have been cared
for and nurtured accepted right away
that is the default answer
it was a very difficult thing for me to
do
to go against that and in the book talk
about how i was wrong in that moment
um because i
didn't do that before i came out to my
parents i
was offended by their
lack of instant accom accommodation and
celebration they were very supportive
they said everything that they knew how
to say at that time but because it was
not instant celebration
i judged them harshly for that and
that's a hard thing to admit when
you're the one coming out because by
default like i said everyone thinks
you're right and everyone thinks you
should be celebrating accepted right
away and to actually challenge that idea
and say no actually that's not where
humans operate from this place of
instant knowledge and accommodation it's
actually a learning process and we
should meet in the middle and we should
be compassionate that's not a popular
opinion i don't think
and so that was difficult for me to talk
about
it's definitely the most
mature
useful position and you've expressed at
the very start of this conversation when
you highlighted your parents context
in regards to the potentially the
mistakes they made and the lessons they
taught you before the age of 10. and you
talk about that in the book as well
understanding the having empathy for
their context right and how that formed
their reaction to that situation i think
is just the most
amazing place to be in because then you
you don't i mean the first thing that
comes to mind is you're not going to
walk around with resentment that they
weren't you know they weren't perfect as
you might see in like a fake movie or
something
but also it i think you can have better
communication when you when you are able
to
lean into their world and understand
them and and it tends to be the case
you'll know because i haven't my mom's
from nigeria i was born in africa like
in all facets of like the the first
generation second generation immigrant
story you actually tend to both want the
same thing mm-hmm so your parents would
have different ways of going about it
yeah right because as you say like often
they don't know about youtube so doctor
or lawyer was the path to this
the happy successful secure life right
and i think immigrants like i had to
with my mom when i said i'm starting a
business i'm never speaking to you ever
again you didn't speak for two years not
just that i'm going to tell all your
family not to speak to you
sadness
having it took me a long time to get to
the place you got to yeah it took me
long too i also for two years was like
held again resentment against my parents
um and i created that drift and
that was how i learned this lesson and i
think it's also because
the world today the internet today
social media today it really really
encourages us to label situations
conversations and things very easily
right wrong cancelled you made a mistake
you cannot redeem yourself you are now
bad you are now good that is not how
humans operate it is not it is not a
realistic lens
through which you should view humans you
know
to
expect people to know everything you
know without having your lived
experience is a really entitled place to
come from and i'm even going to
challenge people online that cancel
people for saying incorrect things and
behaving in incorrect ways and the
person can apologize over and over again
we don't accept apology we're creating a
culture of expecting other people to
operate from our lived experiences how
is that possible
how is that remotely possible my mom did
not grow up with lady gaga bops
she did not grow up with queer culture
so for me to expect her to operate from
a place of my lived experience how is
that math ever going to add up it's
never going to and i know online we like
to sit on our high horse and think it
will but it will never it will never add
up
that's an unpopular opinion i'm sure on
twitter but that's okay i will die on
this hill no i think it's popular it's
definitely a popular opinion here
because okay
um so when you look off into your future
you've got a lot going on movies disney
plus there's all these other things
happening in your life now what is the
next
and i'm i'm scared of us sort of falling
into accolades and numbers and yeah
accomplishments no that's not what is
the next there's a time and place for
those conversations i'm happy the goals
that i have for myself are
um associated with
elevating storytelling so i do
definitely want to be on screen and
behind the camera and produce and write
and start in stories that highly
underrepresented voices that is
something i'm really passionate about
because i believe stories make the world
go around stories are how i understand
myself and other people and i think
there's not every story has to be about
everyone but there should be stories for
everyone and so i'm very passionate
about that so and i just love being
creative in that way so i think
acting producing
i have a book club called lily's library
that's all about south asian stories as
well that's just something i'm that's
just what i'm most passionate about so i
think most of my goals will align with
that
lily thank you for writing such a great
book and i think there's going to be so
many people that are listening to this
now that have heard the context of the
the journey that led up to you creating
this book that might be having questions
about their own foundation
and i also will say i don't know if you
can see if anyone was watching this it's
a short read it's a short concise and i
guarantee you you will hear my voice
reading it to you because i've written
it in that way
so how many pages is that anyway 93.
neither you golf an hour an hour read no
it is it's really it's really digestible
it's the type type of handbag book that
you could travel with and really um if
you're one of those people that doesn't
like tiny letters and thousands of pages
this is definitely a book for you and
it's written from such a place of as
you've expressed today self-awareness
wisdom and vulnerability and those are
always the best books because they are
the truest and the most necessary
so thank you for creating a wonderful
book we do have a closing tradition on
this point let's do it which is the
previous guest that's the question for
the next oh nice okay
how many times
have you been
properly
in love
i'm gonna say
perhaps
including in with myself three times
and i'm not just thinking about love
romantically i don't think love is just
romantically i think one time
romantically
i think one time with myself
and i think
one time after writing this book truly
truly truly
when i saw my mother for all the glory
that she is like i have no problem
saying i'm in love with my mom and the
person she is
um
i was gonna answer with a higher number
but for me what translated what i the
synonym i used for properly was
how many times have i been in love
where both people in the equation became
better versions of themselves
and that's what eliminated a few of the
a few of the numbers i think in every
scenario i'm talking about both people
were better versions of themselves
because of the love
it's a beautiful answer yeah once
romantically it once romantically
figure out which one of you
you know who you are
thank you thank you thank you so much i
appreciate this is such a joy thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]